what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here because we
don't want to apologize that's the name
of the episode the original title I
don't want to apologize and then someone
typed it on chat gbt on how to shorten
it and they called it no apologies the
AI is taking over Jack Reacher season
two get ready that's what it's gonna be
about I have a lot more thoughts than a
typical intro John how are you uh great
I'm really excited for more of your AI
apologies guys leave a like everyone
leave a like leave a like do it reach
for that like button oh God also
subscribe and click that notification
Bell to get notified when our reaction
for episode 6 is up here on the Chanel
these thumbnails on Amazon are very
misleading also fully threatened watch
launchers We sync with your own copy of
Reacher available for our super sexy
Rejects at our patreon page thank you
all for joining just for the show alone
however we also cover several things
over there exclusively reaction
highlights and watch along is included
John are you ready to apologize
I'm always ready for an apology Greg you
ready for an apology already two I'm
ready I'm so sorry I should have said
I'm ready to apologize all times
foreign
[Music]
blockade has been credited with hundreds
of successful search and seizures of
Contraband including oh the only
way to make Molly best death mean
something is by catching whoever killed
her we can't do that if we're shot dead
by crooked cops or rotting away in jail
with her murder pinned on and also
taxidermy
the dog pull over this dog better not be
dead oh he's gonna murder that guy it's
okay
enough of this
pretty old they need to save something
oh they didn't do anything to anybody
doesn't deserve this I told you to stay
off my property
rung his Bell geez
oh yeah there you go there you go let's
see how you like it
peace
Property Owners always ready to go but
never around defeat his dog he's always
in the right around the backyard Corner
Richard break into that computer there
oh the 1989 Batmobile
[Music]
oh man wow
illegal money is awesome my buck or
something I think that's a Bentley
that's a Bentley
the cattle I told you to stay off my
property these are my cows
[Music]
oh put that thingy from the second
episode yeah
oh it's a flashback from the second
episode it all makes sense now
oh damn
oh boy I can't be seen with a
I have nothing if not a Pious man
look it's the war criminal
trying to use that one thing against him
you're interrupting our launch let me
ask you something what kind of man are
you a stupid man
a bitter man a white man you knew I'd
come after you when I saw what you did
to Roscoe you knew I'd see your truck
right outside
a work truck whose beds never had
anything in it other than a keg
I know what you don't know
what's that
what it feels like when I hit you
because if you did you never would have
picked up that paint can now let me tell
you something about Roscoe Conklin she's
a war criminal hello
with the cloth oh
yeah baby
don't even try drop it hey I never liked
you Dawson don't make me prove it
it's just the moment this man arrived at
margraves there's been nothing but
violence and now he's attacked my son
that's it you get him out of here last
time I checked you are my boss
is a call away Junior and the boys are
just minding their own business when
this guy can even started tearing up the
place thank you Earl for being a good
citizen of mongrave
Detective
Roscoe take a Reacher outside
why I beat the out of everyone in
here
get it quick again
in the barrel stupid
well I bet that because she cared about
a Reacher
well I'm telling you man
I feel like Roscoe's gonna die are you
kidding me no no I just got the report
mixed up with something else
easy
what's going on you just fired me whoa
let me talk to the man okay this is
is he going back to jail
Kleiner is impressive charges because he
doesn't want to go to court a lawsuit
lets me ask for discovery about KJ for
character impeachment
[Laughter]
yeah yeah so it's down to Grace files I
told you he didn't leave anything behind
but he left you as Desert Eagle people
thinking about suicide normally give
away their prized possessions right
before they take their lives not a full
year prior good call interesting I want
to see the box that came in just be
careful with it
[Music]
secret box
hahaha
oh
Oh I thought it was a ring when we were
at the motel in Alabama you said gray
used to get his haircut once a week yeah
what is a man with hardly any hair
needed weekly trim
he just likes to keep it tight you know
he wanted you to know
he was proud of him girl
you're the best Barbershop man oh
Barbershop man it's totally dead
Wowie
let me daisies
oh
who buys 116 cattle you buy a lot 20 50
100 it's just I have a lot of animal
feed there's something inside those
animals when my uncle got up to around
120 head he had to follow the state why
so clanner stops at 116. do not file
he'd be subject to State inspectors
coming on his land and he has cows and a
herd that is not that big let it rest
stretch
I swear to God you're not going to have
to worry about Kleiner because I will
cut your balls off myself you
a little sustenance thank sir you
wouldn't happen to have any food or
Salad would you missed mostly are you
picky Bastard with mayo between two
slices of bread right right in front of
it
thank you don't look a gift horse in the
mouth my guy
why would you just ignore this whole
animal thing when Rachel's like right
about everything right
we need direct proof Lincoln counterfeit
cash to cleaner and we don't have it all
the places I didn't do this
there are dying towns all over you just
pick one on a lottery throw a dart at a
map the Old State Route arterial systems
cross right through here shipping fake
cash from here planners trucks can avoid
Federal interstates for most of the trip
literally staying off the radar of cops
with a much bigger presence on busier
highways he had a very well oiled and
thought out operation that's what I
predicted
exactly man it was one step ahead of the
show I'm just such an idiot when it
comes to these things the case I've been
going on for a year which means no funny
money coming into the U.S so there's a
huge backlog of counterfeit cash
overseas making the whole outfit
vulnerable to being caught and that's
what's stored in the animals
maybe someone wants to buy something
really dangerous it's really expensive I
think suitcase nuke but they don't have
the money to do it so they're printing
their own or they want to destabilize
the US economy
bottom line I don't care why they want
to do it you and the FBI can figure all
that out after the people that kill Joe
were dead
grading commit suicide
I'll talk to her
you still gotta talk to teal man you
gotta talk to everybody
sir
ma'am no apologies
damn it I messed that kid up you better
apologize
I'm very sorry for what happened I have
no excuse for my actions I hope you can
forgive me
though I understand if you can't you're
done Richard does Joe and Jack don't
have the same last name I've been
wondering that because even Joe called
him Reacher I apologize no
look at my son
you can't even bring yourself say you're
sorry you're torturing that poor kid I'm
sorry he couldn't defend himself I'm
sorry
I'm sorry the left side of his face
doesn't look like the right
that's the day Jack Reacher hit the road
that is not what we rehearsed you want
to save your town avenge great good
harness that bad people should get
what's coming to him no apologies
that's the name of the epoil got it
she said she wanted dinner at 10 but
instead she had it at six ten six is MP
radio code for send civilian police and
she's taking a shot at me for being a
civilian now
if she can't tell you where she is how
the hell are you gonna find her won't be
a problem oh yeah come on they got way
easier there's gonna be such a
prevailing part of season too she'll
choose a decent discount hotel some and
you'd find near Midtown close to public
transportation you're a place to eat
that's reasonably priced and isn't a
chain restaurant why can't it be a chain
restaurant who would suspect a
McDonald's I tracked you 10 years
together on special investigators I know
what you think figured I'd come to
Midtown avoid tourists find a
serviceable hotel close to mass transit
near Artisan restaurant you found each
other the JW on your brother's punch
list was an EPA investigator named Jimmy
Dupree Wilkes was gone down in his home
dad fed
Ted fed determined it was a random
burglary gone bad murder weapon was a
small caliber nine millimeter subsonic
porkless don't use silencers most not
color guns at all also work there's two
things he stole a life the body was
beaten like a pinata postmortem
I don't see that every day
happens more often than you think
that's what they did to my brother
[Music]
stepped in it now we're gonna kill a
whole lot of people aren't you
he's already started already started
yeah
I wish I could tell you but the first
two chapters of book support cover the
extent of the pollution and the third
chapter the one that deals with the
source is missing a missing Source it's
a guy like for the murders was ordered
an 18-wheelers full of animal feed when
he doesn't need nearly that much do you
see a connection with what we're looking
into not off the top of my head
hell a lot of animal feed though right
right because what I've been saying this
whole time why are you so big genetics
are you a giant
that looks painful instead of hitting
his head on something could something
have a hit his head till I never looked
at the injury that way candy oh now oh
okay
there's a bullet in there
whoa
kind of look like a diamond
done it the cane teals Kane teal would
do it himself I don't feel like he would
but I don't know I mean everyone's a
suspect
there's an empty oil drum right there
pig pen
oil drums cleaner than the river
that's why we're here
why would you go fishing in there yeah
what do you hope to catch EPA came
through here years ago talk about how
the geography makes the toxins settle
here chilling all the crawdads and
catfish said he was going to clean it up
because no one could earn on the water
anymore
you know what he did he died he was
killed
yeah well
so was this town do it for this town Joe
wasn't the first federal agent he had
killed he had woke's taken out too
before his polluting was uncovered
just can't prove it got a text from
Little coin and see how he's ready to
meet game is on you come to clean out
your desk
are we
that is not what you're supposed to do
[Applause]
by now Tail's calling for your arrest
and once you're in custody though take
you out like they try to kill Richard
when they had him locked up oh no I
gotta get you out of town
you can't show your face tomorrow grave
now oh hell no the show's not the same
without her God with me is a small time
trigger pull that makes you think this
will suit him it's been a go-to CI let's
keep a c on the gravy train hey why are
we gonna do this man this case is closed
we got families you let it go this is
not the time for this chat this mess
gotta thank you
it ain't worth our lives too if it was
worth my brother's life it's sure as
hell with yours
so if you don't kill cops who does out
of town Talent a name you know what his
mama called him but he goes by the black
king no you find the Viking you found
your shooter now imma get me a lap dance
and no self-respecting stripper is going
to come to a table with two cops this
chick the pissed off Giant
[Laughter]
oh yeah let's go Neely
yeah you're just shoving messages down
my throat
some nice moves back there
better than the guy who taught him to me
Jack teacher hey
we got there already got a call from
Stevenson saying till once a warrant out
for Roscoe's arrest can't trust
Stevenson I told him she was Furious
about getting fired and that she jumped
out of my car the stoplight and took off
Roscoe I'm here who should do that
Roscoe I love you so much I go to the
source after hours see if I can get
evidence that Nails this thing down boy
scouts kind of doing a legal search
that's for times
besides it's not like I'm killing
someone
[Music]
oh yeah you will I need you to promise
me that you're not going to take out
teal without me
the time comes I'll hold him while you
hit him I love you so much Richard I
said her name normally
I said in normal yeah yep tell me how I
said it
you get to the precinct we'll go through
the Alias database the look of Vikings
see what pops up I think the cop driving
is crooked yeah I'm worried about the
both of them
[Music]
I'm sorry
the woods
I will open the door up stop and shoot
you real quick
tell them now
don't tell them that
yeah you put the wrong guy behind you
oh no
that's real bad my friend and I are
getting out of here I can try and take
you with us but if I do you're going to
jail and they'll kill you inside
so you could either die here and then
they'll come for your family and you
know what they'll do to them it's your
call
wow
oh my god
oh yeah say your prayers match
whoa
Jack swimmer
a lake like Jason Voorhees
you do not mess with the special
investigators you do not miss
the special investigators
oh yeah
this is a size medium
turned into more than you bargained for
when you agreed to help
do me a favor and walk away I love that
detail they actually put on a shirt it
didn't fit
oh here we go thinly impossible
okay
I think there is some type of alarm yeah
that's what I'm worried about
[Music]
oh I had a feeling I should have said it
I hate when I don't see it
you better haul ass out of there yeah
and God though is like neck flaps for a
second he said he was gonna investigate
I was like I bet he climber's dead
because I was thinking about Spivey
being dead yeah yeah and then I was like
based on the run time of this episode
I'd imagine kleiners probably did yeah
these guys probably all have leverage
damn it got like climbers hate when I
don't say something pisses me off gotta
say every Theory pisses me off because
everyone's gonna remember five years
from now when Greg made that prediction
on that YouTube video yeah he's like I
remember when Greg said it he called it
every subsequent season of Reacher
people are gonna be like wow Here Comes
Greg ready to not call another one
re-watch this show without thinking
about when Greg called that moment
ruined the whole experience oh God I do
it for you guys not for me and my own
Pride I do it for you all of you
anyway it's a service damn that was uh
things are getting real real
things are getting real and personal
yeah I love that nuanced touch at the
end there with the cops yeah man because
I was like ah it's maybe just some
crooked guy and then it wasn't just like
he's crooked he was threatened you know
even Jack Reacher seemed to like
understand
you know for a second that is his family
this guy's family is at stake it's not
guys balls yeah and now we know that
that's not an empty threat what a what a
motif what a threat
to make sure some people cooperate like
that's the whoever is due and pulling
the strings here the Assassins that's
their signature calling card now what do
they do when when like a woman is the
main target though because if you don't
have balls to cut off how do they
leverage you I don't know I don't know I
love that that that that that that has
stuck around like like they give you
that idea with Hubble in the first
episode he's like they told me they
would do this and at first you're just
like oh of course they told you that
because like you're just gonna stay in
like they're they're just talking big
and then you see it and now it's just
this like it's like an extra character
that's just with us the whole time and
there hasn't been anything like we're
we're about to hit the sixth episode and
there's only been truly one seriously
graphic moment yeah right and it was
just that with the guy on the one like
they needed to drive that home like how
real of a threat this is and all I
needed was that one like yeah you got
the like the prison fight which was cool
and like some bone crunching stuff
um foreign
but no nothing like what they had what
they had in the second episode with the
crime scene and you know like whenever
they talk about that happen they're just
that just lays the ground floor of yeah
these threats are real and they will do
some messed up stuff and so I love that
because it's it's such a phrase of like
I'll cut your balls off or something
like that you know everything yeah
but then the show of how they do it and
then they get like they crucify you
oh yeah you you list you know when like
a cop is threatened in that position
like he's he's been pushed to that point
and you can see that he wasn't really a
bad guy yes cop and he was even trying
to stop them from investigating earlier
yeah right I love that like his yeah
because he plays it I thought the actor
played it well enough that it could just
be oh you know maybe he just isn't down
for this you know maybe he thinks this
is risky but no they've already gotten
to him have we not met the bigger Baddie
yet that's how it feels and I mean
especially because we've had these
figures like Kleiner and teal and and
all these like corporate guys but aside
from like the the you know Hitman and
the you know like the different little
South American guys who are running
around you know trying to jump reach her
I feel like you know there's it could be
the Viking it could be something else
but I feel like there has to be another
more violent figure involved
that like would get their hands I feel
like we haven't met or you know been
exposed properly to the person who would
get their hands dirty for this stuff
yeah because I feel like they've been
trying to set up like kleiner's son to
be something more
see I keep feeling like yeah like they
they're doing that but he'll
see now I don't know because Kleiner
senior is dead maybe that will be some
kind of twist where it's like I never
had a good relationship with my dad I
had him killed myself or something like
that but I don't know I'm torn between
him being an innocuous Red Herring
versus him being
as suspicious as they may come out to be
yeah and the show does a really good job
at hinting at history with every
character they do a really really good
job you have this thing with Neely and
Jack where it's one buddy from the Army
who actually stays in contact with
and she doesn't feel woke
I know right all right guys
isn't that the way you want to say
things about any woman character
you put them on a barometer culture of
are they woke or not woke you can't just
accept a character you can't just accept
that people have these views and might
just demonstrate Sometimes women have
skills
fighting skills this didn't happen until
people started using the word
investigative skills yeah yeah sometimes
women can also do things without it
having to be in a category called woke
uh yeah I I like I like her a lot and
yeah they hand out you really get the
sense that you know she's probably a
character in previous books I I may be
wrong about that but
she just reads that the way they
introduced her was like a Marvel
character introduction you know like I'm
calling someone special and then like
fans of the book would be like
Punisher called micro all right yeah
some some Vibe like that that's sort of
the impression I had
um and yeah like the way they talk
allude to you know being trained like
the way they've helped train each other
and train together and there's a kinship
between them a Bond's stronger than what
anyone we've seen reach or half he cares
about her yeah actually he doesn't care
about people he cares about her we know
Richard cares those muscles can't cover
up that heart
blood to that heart with him his his
heart must beat like a kettle drum yeah
well I love this their Rapport back and
forth because they're so comfortable
with each other and like their
friendship really plays like even it's
just like a small thing but even the way
they're like changing together and it's
not a thing like it almost feels weird
to call attention but the fact that they
don't really at all like shows how
comfortable but how just kind of you
know at ease they are with each other
without it having to be any kind of
other thing than that yeah you know and
uh
I mean I don't anticipate anything too
terrible happening to her but with her
going off on her own I'm a little
worried it's like she's a season two
character I hope so yeah I mean I feel
like she could maybe later on in like a
season three or four be called into
greater apparel but I feel like yeah
this will this will set up the
connective tissue because we're probably
not gonna see Mark uh you know uh Roscoe
and Finley I don't deep dive into the
comments because I'm constantly worried
about getting spoiled yes
um you guys have been really good about
not mentioning if Alan Richardson is
American or dad I still don't know I
still have no idea either I'm waiting to
find out
um yeah so I I have no idea who will
actually die or if they all make it out
of this season alive or anything like
that or if Neely will be a character who
prevails however this sense that I get
from the comments is that if I'm not
mistaken this is based off of the 12th
book Jesus so many books it's like one
of those airport novels right like
there's like a billion of these yeah
like put in a good way I guess
well I've heard these supporting
characters are better flesh out here
than they usually are the books oh cool
um oh that's nice I I really like maybe
read a comment or two that said that so
I I don't know what the actual General
consensus is really going off of like
one or two opinions I read yeah uh but
if I'm not mistaken it's pretty faithful
to the book uh it certainly seems to
please many more book fans than the
films did yeah yeah uh well it's
primarily investigative where is it Jack
Retros like get to an action scene the
movie yeah I want to see an action scene
yeah whereas here I'm like action's cool
and all but like I'm just so like I just
love watching them figure this out yeah
yeah and then it's cool how this is like
us
it starts off like a small town crime
that is escalating escalatingly getting
bigger in your uncovering corruption and
then the corruption
becomes more personal to the characters
pasts yeah like how they did that with
Roscoe like I don't know this gray guy
and I don't really care that he died but
I care that Roscoe cares and is
heartbroken by it isn't that her daddy
yeah maybe I could be I could be wrong
about that
you see their biological dad
I thought her dad was a cop or something
like that I don't know I'd have to go
back and look for the detail
wouldn't she say they killed my dad at
any point probably not they killed gray
yeah that makes more sense I know they
still call it wrong about that his
brother called him
yeah and I'm like is is Joe like your
adoptive brother or something or you you
look the same so like do you call Joe
Reacher seems like you just call him Joe
yeah and then Jack's even said at one
point to
um
Roscoe like Mary Beth is her name Mary
Beth Molly Beth Molly Beth died
she cared about one reach that whole
thing about she cared about one reach
her and she died yeah
so Joe has to be the other original yeah
yeah
I mean I that's how I'm that's how I've
always assumed that they are
biologically both reachers and not just
like I consider him a reason look and
apparently they look exactly the same
yeah they sound similar and
and even the cast of The the brothers
and the young versions of them to look
pretty similar yeah so they have to be
yeah I know it gets confusing
it's weird town where they just don't
call either but yeah no either way
though even without the full context of
who gray is to I I agree yeah like who
he is to Roscoe like just the way that
she plays that and I love like her and
Jasper going over the I do think it's a
little suspicious The Jasper didn't like
enhanced this wound the first version on
it that's right he's been pulling this
straight he's the least uh suspecting
character but but I loved her just
little
like the little nuances of her
performance having to power through this
really kind of traumatic reliving of
this event but also getting to the
bottom of the clues I guess I could see
it from a Jasper standpoint like this
town doesn't experience murder
even though they have us even though
they have the best goddamn Cups
he's too friendly and Roscoe
highly over qualified guys yeah
seriously
um
Roscoe trained by the FBI at all
um but the town hasn't experienced
murder so I could see how if they didn't
even think to look for it they wouldn't
have and yeah and if it really looks
like the particular situation that it
was supposed to look like then yeah you
would just kind of go okay he probably
hit his head on the chair Etc yeah
um
but yeah I mean it's it's cool it's cool
there's some so it's a bit of
swashbuckling vibe to it at times too
like it it
pushes past uh just investigative
mystery into treasure hunt yeah this is
this show has a really interesting tone
for what kind of show it is because I've
seen various you know uh crime
investigation procedural mini series
very popular genre lots of different
cultures have them you know especially
in prevalence now and this one has a
certain element of of fun despite like
the Grim nature of so many of the
circumstances and the sordid you know
spiral of the actual history like but
it's still like it's a swashbuckling I
think does kind of Broach on it because
it is it does have
like a very very grounded sort of
Adventure kind of quality and you're
like going all through like they depict
these areas of you know the country in a
very Vivid and tangible way to
so yeah like even though it doesn't feel
like you're like swamped territory like
true to detective I've only seen the
first season But True Detective felt
like you know uh an icky
Noir just Southern Gothic detective show
like and I loved I love that season that
was great
um that really had that Flair we're here
I wouldn't remiss someone for thinking
it's PG-13 until suddenly you're like oh
there's a lot of hard efforts of nudity
oh surprising violence but the rest of
the show looks like it can be like a
PG-13 show until some like R-rated
pops up you're like oh yeah is there an
R-rated show well and I like that they
use those pulpy things in a way that
doesn't come across with an R-rated
attitude it's like they go into a strip
club and there isn't nudity in that
scene but it doesn't feel like there's
no requisite like we're in a strip club
kind of shot it's just like oh yeah
there's some nudity in the background
but whatever that's not the point you
know it's kind of yeah and even in the
those moments like when they change
together like it is just kind of casual
and you're like yeah you know like this
doesn't feel mature explicit or
exploitative in any way yeah
yeah yeah it's good stuff yeah this is
good stuff and there's a lot of great
unspoken qualities between Roscoe and
Reacher as well I love the actress plays
Roscoe she is terrific man I don't know
if I've ever seen her before but I hope
to see her again
I hope she gets so many roles I get sick
of her and root for her downfall I can't
wait to see you again all right guys
well thank you so much for being here
please be sure to go ahead leave a like
subscribe do all those things and last
but not least let's end this with
shouting out some patrons
Ryan Smith caught you right at the end
of the month there welcome Kevin Meek
you're amazing Adrian Tims you're
tremendous Ryan Baines I love you
Jeffrey Robinson just want to give you a
back rub real nagas cuddle with me Lex
you're the bestestist Marco fan 101 fart
on my face let's kick it into Heather
gear Ian Simon stop watching me when I
shower Songhai Glover can you make me
some pancakes Jacob Neptune those photos
were supposed to be in private I bow
down to you Kayla the king Alan Ling we
can't discuss legal issues on the
YouTubes Logan Burton do you want to go
the promise me yes or no Kiara he's my
son too aircon's 39 King of the prime
numbers KUSI KUSI you can't say things
like that in front of my friends Nick
hex whoa this is a kid's show all right
this is for children this is John
January if you want to bring another
person into the bedroom you gotta run it
by me first one Longoria that is not a
toy Gail Ferguson did I say you could
have some of my fries Cliff Rodriguez
give me back my family Master T oh sorry
I didn't know you were doing that
anymore the door without knocking goat
Nation I'm not mad I'm just disappointed
florenza Baxter maybe put a towel on
when you come out of the shower huh
differently saying come in from the rain
and get warm or go tonsil what are you
we're just staring at like staring at me
like that
Lauren American Horse you're a gosh darn
American hero and Tim and I respect you
simply faded open a window for Christ's
sakes some nebulist Jester 94. so Justin
Martin you have time to put out a tweet
but not text me back is that it Rosie
Beatty you never came to one of my
soccer games not one Colin I got you on
camera you're the one who backed into my
car Philip J Smith Jr you've just been
served sorry Jen Smith
I do not want to go to church with you
Melanie LeBlanc I found five friends and
they found five friends so so we'll join
your network marketing company it's good
thank you guys for being here
always personalized customized messages
tailored to each of your personality
every one of you and our one-on-one
interactions have we all had definitely
this is based on mountains of
interaction
love y'all see you soon
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]